Let's get right into audience questions today.
First one is about these so-called secret
Trump voters.
Hey, David, I keep hearing about shy or secret
Trump voters sometimes called the silent majority.
Is this really a thing?
Do the polls not understand or account for
Trump voters who simply aren't willing to
say they are going to vote for Trump?
So, listen, in broad strokes, the answer is
that the secret Trump voters don't really
exist.
There are people who point to 2016 and they
say, look, the polls were so wrong.
People clearly weren't telling pollsters that
they were planning to vote for Donald Trump
because they felt some kind of public shame
or they were embarrassed or whatever the case
may be.
The polls were basically right in 2016.
Hillary was winning by three in the popular
vote.
She won by two point to these states, like
I believe that there was one state that really
was wrong, but for the most part, the battleground
states that were close, that the margins of
error were accounting for the actual results.
So 2016 doesn't really give us evidence that
there were secret Trump voters, the idea being
they hide their preference from pollsters
until they actually go out and votes.
A big difference between 2016 and 2020 is
that I don't know why someone would be particularly
unwilling to admit today that they plan to
vote for Trump in a poll.
Remember this, your family, you know your
friends.
Nobody's going to find out how you voted in
a poll.
A lot of the polls now are completely automated.
So it's not even that you might be embarrassed
to tell the pollster that you're planning
on voting for Trump.
There really would be no reason why if I got
a poll and says this is, you know, SRS press
one if you plan to vote for Biden, plus press
two, if you plan to vote for Trump, why would
I be shy about just answering truthfully there?
The only argument that could be made would
be Trump ists have coordinated to claim they
are voting for Biden in order to give Biden
a lead in the polls, which will motivate more
Trump voters to get out and vote in November.
It's a complete argument.
You know, it's a post hoc argument made to
justify something we don't actually have evidence
for, and it makes no sense to me whatsoever.
There were no you know, there's no evidence
that there were there are more shy Trump voters
than there were shy Obama voters or shy Hillary
Clinton voters or whatever.
Certainly there is a significant cultural
divide in this country where there could be
social stigma at work from being one of the
few Trump voters.
If you work at some tech firm in Austin, Texas,
a state that's likely to go to Trump, but
Austin is much more blue, maybe you might
not tell your coworkers that you're going
to vote for Donald Trump, but why would you
lie in a poll with your coworkers?
Would never know that.
So my sense is it's not so much that what
could turn the election would be that Trump
has way more support than the polls say because
of secret Trump voters.
What's more likely to me is that there is
a part of the base that doesn't get involved
until election time and maybe they are more
prevalent on the Republican side than the
Democratic side.
Maybe Joe Biden's support is fully represented
in the polls, but some Trump support is still
sitting out there as an, I don't know, or
third party or whatever, because people aren't
necessarily paying attention yet or whatever
the case may be.
I'm still manning the argument.
I suspect that that would be a small portion
of the electorate.
And I don't imagine that you are going to
see any significant amount of shy Trump supporters
or reticent or maybe embarrassed Trump supporters
who are going to vote for Trump in November.
But for one reason or another are lying to
pollsters today.
Last thought, the other argument is it's not
that there are shy Trump supporters.
It's that Trump's supporters are skeptical
of polls, skeptical of polls, so they opt
out.
Well, the polls are normalized and adjusted
to make sure that the samples are representative.
If you were, imagine that you had trouble
getting Trump supporters to respond because
they hate pollsters.
And so you would think, oh, well, you're underrepresented.
Trump supporter Trump supporters in the poll.
Now you just adjust and normalize the sample
to account for that.
And pollsters have a number of different different
methods that are scientifically, statistically
acceptable.
In that case, if we're wrong, then we will
know very, very soon.